last time we were in Europe every time I
ask the players who were the favourites
for this event they were magnuson car
was a rapid tournaments a blitz
tournament in magna so obviously the
number one player our America's not here
thankee car oh well it's not a blitz
tournament anymore who do you consider
to be the favorite coming into this
event well I think all the guys that are
high rated I'm not the one to predict
what's going to happen in a tournament
that i'm in i think everyone just wants
to give their best thinking about
fabiano sinking boat rev 1 i'm seeking
work together and basically it was a
player in this field so you know the
field is so talk I guess you'd have to
save a share simply because the way he's
landed I hope he's laying down in August
let's put it that way he's now in very
good shape so he has several good
results very good results in a row and
normally when you aspire to you play
better considering my last few
tournaments if I keep the momentum i
would say i'm typically one of the
favorites he's clearly one of the
favorites but named naming him as own
you know a clear favourite though i
think is a bit of an overstatement well
he's done very well against these say
2720 2730 players like in dormant for
example i think overall it's not been
against absolutely claris i think he's
going to come back down to earth and
this vat i think that anyone can
potentially win the tournament i mean i
wouldn't even pick out a clear favor
although i think i have very good
chances and all quite clearly the bottom
seat here so no pressure nobody's
singled you out as the bottom see it
even though I passed several people the
very polite people just players on nice
people it's me it's all like a beautiful
hollywood movie I think it's a time for
me to win this tournament now and events
in Bilbao normal toward a little moment
of suspense when the main character in
the movie stuff time but you know it
he'll make it there at the end